hello you're watching the daily climate
show on sky news
on today's programme the uk
is less prepared for climate change than
five years ago
a push to make heating your home more
sustainable and even more affordable
and the refill and reuse campaign hoping
to reduce
millions of tons of plastic waste
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show
where we track the changes happening to
our world right now
and we meet those who are coming up with
the solutions
now the uk has failed to adapt to the
increasing threat of
climate change that is the warning from
a new report by the climate change
commission
it urges the government to act to stop
more people from dying and losing their
homes to extreme weather events
the government says its targets on
reducing co2 emissions are
a world first lisa holland reports from
aberdeen
in this street everybody knows wendy the
flood warden
when the heavy rains come she goes door
to door warning that danger is imminent
morning john how are you today she says
living with the impact of climate change
can be terrifying
it is really frightening because there's
very little that you can do
to mitigate against the river and the
weather
and the tide but at the end of the day
you're still at the mercy of the
elements as it were a 20 million pound
flood defense scheme is being built in
the aberdeenshire town of stonehaven
a place so prone to flooding that the
river charon can burst its banks within
just an hour or so of the alarm being
raised
lilian has had her house flooded twice
before
the older you get the scarier it gets
because you don't
cope with it the same you're trying to
leave your home
if you see the rain you just don't go
out
by 2080 this river will contain a third
more water
because of climate change temperatures
are rising and so are sea levels
but government advisors say the uk is
not prepared
for what lies ahead
and the threats posed by climate change
are getting worse
with criticism that the government's
response is inadequate
lisa holland sky news aberdeenshire well
let's just remind ourselves of the
situation
so far uk land temperatures have risen
by around 1.2 degrees celsius from
pre-industrial
levels and sea levels here have risen
by 16 centimeters since 1900
with an increased risk of flooding
and since 2018 over 4
000 heat related deaths have been
recorded in england that's according to
this assessment
even under the most ambitious emissions
cut scenarios the uk
is likely to experience around an
additional
0.5 degrees celsius increase in annual
average temperature by 2050
but in the last five years since the
publication of the previous report more
than half a million homes have been
built
that are not resilient to those rising
temperatures
well a government spokesperson has
responded to that report
saying the uk was the first major world
economy to set a target of net
zero greenhouse gas emissions by 2050.
our plan to further reduce emissions in
2035 by at least
78 compared to 1990 levels
is the highest reduction target by a
major economy to date
we welcome this report and will consider
its recommendations closely as we
continue to demonstrate
global leadership on climate change
ahead of cop
26 in november well let's speak now to
the chief executive
of the climate change committee which
published the report chris stark
chris good to talk to you a poor report
card
you've given the government there what
are you recommending
we looked at 61 separate risks
also some opportunities and what we've
found is i'm afraid that the uk is not
preparing anywhere near as adequately as
you might expect
that we are for those risks and these
are real issues your report raised some
of them
so we need i think people in this
country need the government to put
better plans in place to manage those
kind of climate risks
and we've done in this report something
i think we haven't been able to do
before
which is to give a much more integrated
sense of the steps that we need to take
not just to tackle
these risks but also to manage net zero
itself which we think will be undermined
if we don't
take these steps to adapt to climate
change we're looking at some pretty
devastating images
on our screen of what happens to
people's lives
when we don't take the necessary
precautions
what is already taking place to mitigate
climate change
so what we've seen for the government
over the last few years has been focused
mostly on things like flooding
now that is a really important hazard
that comes from climate change
we haven't seen them focus on a whole
list of other risks which frankly
we have been raising with them now for
several years things
like overheating in buildings now this
is a really hot day for large suedes of
the country
it's not for me in scotland i should say
but for the southeast
it certainly is and we see overheating
now is that a bigger and bigger claim at
risk
that's something we've been seeing for
more than a decade to the government and
yet
in the last five years since we
published our last response
we've built over half a million homes
that are not
fit for the kind of temperatures that
we'll have in the future they are poorly
adapted to that they don't have shutters
in the windows they're not well
ventilated so they've got their work cut
out for them chris stark
good to talk to you thank you thank you
so
we've heard the warning and the
recommendations well now let's
take a look at our data dashboard
this here this shows the level of human
induced
global warming since the industrial
revolution
just over 1.2 degrees and it's
ticking up the whole time global warming
of more than
one and a half degrees celsius could
potentially expose the world to more
extreme weather
greater economic losses lower crop
yields higher sea levels and
greater damage to wildlife and their
habitats
and this figure here this is the total
amount of global
co2 emissions 2.41
trillion tons and again ticking up
while we watch it well let's take a look
at
some of the day's other climate news now
and companies in australia are being
asked to suggest
offshore locations where carbon dioxide
can potentially
be buried it's part of the australian
government's plan
to help cut emissions the country
already has the world's biggest
commercial carbon capture and storage
project where co2 is being injected
under barrow island that's off western
australia
it contributed to a 5 fall in
australia's carbon emissions
last year a 19th century painting has
inspired plans to develop the landscape
of a national trust property in devon
the painting is believed to be by the
11th baronet sir thomas dyke ackland
whose family gifted the killerton estate
to the trust
nearly 80 years ago the refurbishment
will help it to capture more carbon
and help the land wildlife and livestock
cope with more extreme weather
orcas have complex social structures
including the ability to have close
friendships
a study that used drones to film the
killer whales found that they interact
most with those of the same sex and
similar age within their group of
relatives known as
their pod researchers at the university
of exeter found that as they get older
orcas tend to grow apart there are
believed to be around
50 000 of them left in the wild
now with the weather like it is at the
moment it's hard to imagine isn't it
needing
to heat your home but with climate
change can come
extreme weather and there are now calls
for a
fair heat deal to make moving from
fossil fuel boilers to clean heat pumps
more
affordable now currently heat pump
installation that can
cost as much as 10 000 pounds
the proposed fair heat deal though would
include free heat pumps
and insulation for fuel poor and low
income households and grants for
everyone else
according to the energy saving trust
replacing your old gas boiler with a
standard air heat pump in a four
bedroom detached house could save you
around 375
pounds a year and switching from an old
gas boiler to a heat pump system
could reduce household co2 emissions by
as much as 4
700 kilograms a year that's the
equivalent to taking two cars off the
road
or it's as much carbon as driving from
london to bristol 140 times
well the senior policy advisor at the
independent climate think tank
e3g juliette phillips joins me now
uh juliet good to talk to you it's
important to remember
isn't it that what goes on in our own
homes is just as important as what the
big companies are doing
yes absolutely and with um heating our
homes representing around 14
of the uk's green homes uh greenhouse
gas emissions even on a hot day today
it's still a really important topic to
be discussing
and what else do you think that the fair
heating deal should do
so um the fair heat deal sets out a
number of different um
requests to um mainly treasury focused
on
rebalancing the cost of heating um and
paving the way forward
including things like um covering all
the costs for low-income households
as well as providing attractive
incentives to for those who do have um
support and are able to pay for them
some measures themselves as well as
focusing on the consumer protection side
recognizing
you know it's quite a big change going
into a home and um changing the heating
system so it's really important the high
quality
installations being supported across the
country
julia phillips really good to talk to
you thank you thanks a lot
now have you ever refilled a soap bottle
or filled a container with cereal or
pasta in a store
well if not here is how to join the
refill revolution
[Music]
so
finally even shakespeare has gone
sustainable
a production of as you like it is being
staged with a set
props and costumes made from responsibly
sourced
repurposed and recyclable materials the
play
is on atlee at the watermill theater
that's near newbury in berkshire
and the set designer katie lease says
that the show
has environmentalism at its very core
well that is all for today tomorrow the
british campaign to get
turkey on board with climate action
that's ahead of cop 26 in
glasgow that's at the same time tomorrow
here
on sky news hope to see you then